miles bridges on the hornets who is uh
bisque one of the best
rapper slash ball players we've seen in
a lot of times he's the best rapper he's
the best
nba rapper in the league right now do
you think he's better than dame lillard
music wise yeah i think he's making
better music for sure music wise yeah
like the damage damn doll is a lyric-y
hip-hop head
you know what i'm saying he's more about
the bars you're not gonna expect dame to
drop the type of [ __ ] he dropped and he
really can rap you feel me like he a
real deal rapper miles bridges you can
play [ __ ] in the club miles bridges is
going to make the whole shake that ass
you know what i'm saying and that's what
the young [ __ ] and the [ __ ] want to
hear you feel me yeah [ __ ] who really
respect music
wanna hear damn you know what i'm saying
and i
like
i know i've listened to the cds you feel
me but
skiller probably listens to damn city
you know what i'm saying right
i have listen i haven't i haven't
listened today you listen to that you
see i'm saying i don't know i mean
listen shout out to damian lillard i
don't know anyone who's there no i [ __ ]
with
i just haven't like tapped in with his
albums no that ain't really like a [ __ ]
homeboy though like [ __ ] like i know
it's people from sabrani all that type
of [ __ ] like that's really my [ __ ] so
i got music with that mm-hmm so like
it's like and then like
i ain't gonna take it away from him and
say that he don't really respect music
because i know for a fact skilling when
the [ __ ] really live and respect music
that's why you record as much as damn i
record you feel me probably the same
amount if not more sometimes you feel me
it's just
the type of music that dollar putting
out or will put out is not the [ __ ]
that's gonna catch his ass right but if
we scrolling on instagram like he say
like [ __ ] yeah yeah stop and watch
happy birthday no it's like you would
watch a battle rapper battle rap but you
ain't gonna go listen to his music
like i like him bart for bart on the
radio i want to hear him freestyle like
i want to hear that there's a lot of
people like that especially on the
battle side i feel like a lot of battle
guys that
are aren't great at uh actually making
records only one of them [ __ ] made a
good song
calico and i [ __ ] with i [ __ ] with uh so
i think sue's dope
i like that um 2 a.m madness or some
[ __ ] that's so surprising straight
little album
i [ __ ] with it it's called 2am
mazzy did up jordan album that was dope
they did too right
but did you see the controversy of miles
posting the cup of pink lemonade
is when you see something like that
because it was being limited i'm sure it
was but he's there's a big bag that's
pending right now for him yeah as you
kind of being like the big homie like
i taste them yeah i text them like hey
man even though it was just pink
lemonade you got to understand listen on
god in heaven that's exactly what i said
i'm like [ __ ] what you doing posting
pink lemonade brother
yeah for what like for what bro why
fumble the bag
whoever in your coast whoever your close
friend
everybody in your coach fans don't want
you to win for one but whoever your
close friends that you don't be around
daily or that you don't fully trust
and especially no hugs bro you got to
take them out of there bro and not even
play around with your close friends like
that because
a [ __ ] gonna do what they did i
know he i know he didn't post pink
lemonade on his [ __ ] regular story
he's probably putting in his his close
friend [ __ ] he put it in his close
friends
[Music]
do it for the back available he gonna
get that back and he young and he wanted
to take her back he wanted to post a
pink lemonade if anybody else posted
some pink lemonade that was a bum ass
[ __ ] in the lead they would let him
post pink lemonade my man's about to get
a bag get off his back they want to try
to [ __ ] it up yeah get off his back you
feel me he i don't think he should have
posted pink lemonade but if he got that
right like that's one of his rights so
yeah it was pink lemonade get off his
back